[Musique]
mesure phare des cinq candidats philippe
juvin mise en place de peines de prison
de courte durée aujourd'hui moins de
deux ans on va pas en prison quatre
d'entre eux en tout cas sont totalement
centriste et macro compatibles en toutes
circonstances sauf depuis qu'ils sont en
campagne alors là d'un seul coup il se
met à découvert le problème de
l'immigration a rivalisé de fermeté dans
la proposition territorialisation des
peines pour valérie pécresse rétablir un
service militaire et de sécurité
obligatoire pour six mois mais pour
michel barnier le milieu de terrain
marseillais dimitri payet s'apprête à
tirer un corner lorsqu'il est touché à
la tête par une bouteille d'eau en
plastique lancée depuis les tribunes
réduction drastique de l'immigration et
xavier bertrand ont envoyé l'armée dans
les quartiers difficiles pour eric
ciotti
les dirigeants du football français
doivent maintenant arrêter de se cacher
derrière leur petit doigt il faut qu'on
arrête de se renvoyer systématiquement
la balle comme ça a été même le cas hier
soir au moment de prendre les décisions
après plus de deux heures de
négociations la rencontre a été
définitivement arrêté huit citations sur
le las la suite des événements ce sont
des actes qui font honte tout simplement
aux sports et aux valeurs qui sont
celles du sport qui sont des valeurs de
rassemblement et qui sont contraires
fois qu'on analyse six portiers mecs
quand une fois qu'on a dit ça ça veut
dire qu'il faut que les clubs eux-mêmes
prennent leurs dispositions vis-à-vis
des supporters il faut que les
présidents de clubs s'y met tous on ne
peut pas accepter ces actes de violence
parce que évidemment il n'ya pas que les
joueurs qui les subissent dimitri payet
mais il ya aussi les spectateurs qui
regardent oui il faut prendre un
certains nombres décision il faut pas
frapper non plus à l'emporte-pièce les
gens qui se comportent bien et qui
organise bien qu'on sera obligé
d'interrompre tous les matches parce que
ce sera écrit noir sur blanc sur quels
critères on interrompt le match à ce
moment là et j'espère avant la ligue les
instances sportives des clubs vont se
poser la question mais comment on va
faire parce que les droits télé les
droits télé ils vont rentrer que s'il ya
des matches qui passe à la télé les
familles des enfants et soudain une
voiture qui fonce au milieu du défi
selon les médias américains il s'agirait
du rappeur d'aréli brooks dans ce clip
on le voit notamment posé de rendre son
insu attentes affaire de contrôle du
conducteur en fuite pour l'instant les
enquêteurs ne privilégient aucune piste
selon les autorités locales l'incident a
fait plusieurs morts et plus de 20
blessés dont une douzaine d'enfants
françois hollande j'étais à votre place
à son arrière et qu'est ce qu'il a dit
il a dit que si news était la chaîne de
zemmouri la raison vous c'est aussi la
chaîne de le pen depuis trois mois j'ai
été invité sur toutes les chaînes
privées parce que j'avais un livre à
présenter je note que le service public
ne m'a pas du tout invité pour mon livre
mes projets l'habitude c'est pas la
première fois c'est pas le premier livre
qui est ainsi boycotté par service
public j'ai le sens de l'émission
équitable aussi bon et alors qu'est ce
que donc vous n'aurez pas chez lui vous
n'aurez pas si tendance est aussi tout à
fait qu'il n'en mangerai pas leur nom
vous avez été invités de laurent ruquier
et l'easa là c'est vrai
au tribunal au dessus du village de
lorgues et la flamme et j'avais oublié
vous avez raison avez vous pardonnez moi
l'expression pété les plombs non j'ai
pas pété les plombs j'ai une expression
totalement inapproprié que j'ai corrigé
à l'antenne dans les secondes les
minutes qui ont suivi qui remplacera
emmanuel macron s'il devait lui aussi à
subir
excusez moi vous y pensez jamais ça
c'est du journalisme d'investigation en
profondeur si charles pasqua est évident
et c'est ce que je voulais dire il
aurait mis une bonne fessée médiatique
j'aurais pu dire qu'il se serait
retourné ou qui se retourne dans sa
tombe je pense qu'il aurait passé un
sale quart d'heure et photos d'animaux
les plus drôles de l'année on va se
régaler la voilà c'est un petit adverse
6 et muette oui je vous laisse apprécier
ou pas
phaidon a subi une coloscopie et kamala
harris a été présidente pendant une
heure 25 je pense qu'on a à faire la
passation de pouvoir la plus gênante que
les états unis comme quoi du début à la
fin des états unis ce sera un pays de
colomb il faut te gagnant de bal à la
voix si celle d'un singe qui a l'air
très très incommodés abbas était un peu
rapide soyez il avait l'air un peu à
corriger par le chili avait à
l'entrejambe